on ne s'y fait jamais pourtant mon frère
jean et moi lui surtout nous ne sommes
plus si jeune à nos âges le plus souvent
on a déjà pris sa retraite parfois
depuis longtemps et nous avions subi une
terrible alerte il ya déjà quatre ans à
la disparition de votre père antoine
l'homme de ta vie ton compagnon ton
indéfectibles soutiens et partenaires
pendant 67 ans mais on y croit jamais
vraiment et puis nous avions une excuse
le 18 mars 2010 au moment de te recevoir
au 13e fauteuil celui de racine
l'auteur préféré le ton père andré
jacobs jean d'ormesson avait posé dessus
sur et maman baissant la voix pour mieux
se faire entendre
nous vous aimons madame ce jour là sous
la coupole sont que nous étions emporter
par l'émotion
nous avions fini par te croire vraiment
immortels mais ainsi que le dit
l'ecclésiaste
il y a un temps pour tout et finalement
le temps est venu pour toi aussi tu te
retirer avec ton calme
la douceur est à délicatesse presque sur
la pointe des pieds
et pour nous le temps de pleurer
maman que j'aime
le hasard de la naissance ou plutôt la
fortune m'avait accordé le privilège
d'être le benjamin de tes trois fils
celui qui pouvait espérer rester le plus
tardivement sur tes genoux mon fauteuil
préféré comme tu avais invité guise et
de ce même stratagème avec ta propre
mère notre grand mère yvonne jacob ton
modèle de droiture de tolérance et
d'humanité dont les survivants qui
l'avait connu se souvenait que jusque
dans l'enfer de bergen à il avait
continué de la plaie avec respect madame
jacobs temps elle portait encore de
dignité alors que pourtant un matricule
tatoué sur le bras gauche était devenu
votre seule identité mais les
circonstances ont en décidé autrement et
tu es devenu en un peu plus de 40 ans la
mère de temps de françaises et de
français qui t'ont choisi j'allais dire
adopter
pour seconde mère bien sûr nous
n'oublions pas nous n'oublierons jamais
le bruit et la fureur des insultes et
des outrages proférés sans retenue
durant c'est difficile semaine
je
il fallait radi
violence fait chaque année
à des centaines de milliers de femmes au
nom d'un ordre moral débordés
aujourd'hui
ce bruit et cette fureur ont été depuis
longtemps magnifiquement balayée par la
reconnaissance et l'affection
respectueuse que manifeste le pays tout
entier alors au fil des années nous
avons appris à tout partager avec des
proches et des moins proches et même des
inconnus des million d'inconnues
nous avons même appris à apprécier cette
familiarité certes respectueuse mais qui
irrite est tout de même un peu notre
père en même temps qu'elle ne
remplissait de fierté le bonheur
cette familiarité donc avec laquelle nos
interlocuteurs parfois de simples
passants dans la rue s'autorisait ton
prénom comme s'ils avaient eux aussi
sauter sur ses genoux
enfin
depuis vendredi dans la peine le chagrin
nous sommes devenus les témoins prévus
mais tout de même et bailly d'un pays en
deuil
presque apaisé sinon un instant
réconcilier comme pour honorer les
valeurs d'humanité et d'universalité à
la source de tous tes combats est
d'abord de celui de la réconciliation
pour une europe de paix une europe de
liberté une europe de solidarité et de
progrès partagée
cet hommage national
pour lequel nous vous remercions
monsieur le président de la république
en présence de vos prédécesseurs y
compris du président chirac que nous
savons présent par la pensée cet hommage
cet hommage est un ultime victoire sur
les camps de la mort et cette nuit de
mars 1945
peut-être celle du 18 au 19 mars à
bergen belsen lorsqu'avant même ton
retour de la corvée de travail sous les
yeux désemparé 2000 où ta soeur les caps
ont repris le corps épuisé et sans vie
de votre mère notre grand mère pour le
jeter à la fosse commune des 6 millions
de corps et de cendre qui recouvre à
jamais notre histoire
les dizaines des centaines et milliers
de témoignages de respect et d'affection
reçu ces derniers jours sont autant de
rayons de soleil d'éclat de lumière
d'instants de bonheur en définitif de
raisons pour nous tes enfants et petits
enfants de dire tout haut au pays tout
entier clair et fort mais aussi avec
tout notre émotion notre affection et
notre profonde reconnaissance en ce
moment solennel ce dernier mot que tu as
prononcé faiblement mais si
distinctement avant de t'endormir pour
retrouver papa pour toujours ce dernier
mot merci